paris marseille bordeaux strasbourg des
villes aux couleurs et aux accents de
l'ukraine
des milliers de manifestants se sont
rassemblés partout en france pour
dénoncer la guerre et soutenir les
ukrainiens ici à caen du bleu et du
jaune jusque dans les vêtements moi
c'était une évidence de venir en soutien
de la population ukrainienne est de
montrer qu'on n'était pas du tout
indifférent à ce qui se passait dans
leur pays même si j'ai pas moi qui va
lui changer mon fusil je veux pas les
défendre mais minimum c'est être présent
côte à côte à limoges comme ailleurs des
français des ukrainiens parce que c'est
important de montrer notre soutien aux
ukrainiens qui sont ils présents ici
avec nous à l'image mais aussi aux
ukrainiens qui sont chez eux aujourd'hui
bloquée en ukraine c'est très émouvant
c'est parce qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
qui sont venus se tenir de crem et dans
les défilés certains sont prêts à aller
plus loin dans leur soutien nous on a la
possibilité d'héberger un couple et deux
enfants à la limite
parmi les manifestants des candidats à
la présidentielle anne hidalgo à
bordeaux fabien roussel à lille ou
yannick jadot à paris